Now we're going to actually
install our workshop
which is the Android Studio program.
I suggest you watch me so that you
can have a sense of what the process
looks like and then follow the text
version instructions at your own pace.
Also keep in mind that
these are large files.
You're going to want to have a strong
and stable internet connection.
For students with slower and
more unreliable Internet,
you might want to consider finding
a wired Internet connection.
I've created the walk through for
how to download Android Studio on
two different operating systems.
I have instructions for Windows and
instructions for Mac computers.
I'll give you a moment, go ahead and
click on which one applies to you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, I'm going to be installing
Android Studio on a Windows machine.
Please note that this screencast
was done on April 7th, 2015.
And I say that just because
sometimes the screens or
the icons that you might see
while installing Android Studio
could change depending
on what version it is.
We're going to give you a text version
to go along with the screen cast, and
since it's easier to change
the text version than to
go through re-recording
an entire screen cast
that will be a little bit more up
to date than the screen cast will.
All right so to start off go ahead and
open a web browser and
go to the Android Studio website.
It's a link to the instructor notes,
you do not have to type this in.
All right, so once you've arrived at the
site, you should see a big green button
that's pretty obvious, that says
Download Android Studio for Windows.
So go ahead and click that.
All right, and that's going to take
you to the license for Android Studio.
You're welcome to go ahead and
read that I'm going to scroll to
the bottom, sign my rights away, and
then click this Download Android Studio
for Windows button.
All right, we did want to download this,
so we do want to keep it.
I'm going to press Keep.
Okay, and if you look right here, this
is a little bit less than a gig of data.
And that's about equivalent to
downloading a movie file of reasonable
quality, so
you can judge how long this will take
based on your Internet connection.
Okay, once it's finished downloading,
go ahead and double-click the file.
We did in fact want to run this,
so click run.
Yes, we did want to allow
it to make changes.
All right.
And now we're at the Android Studio
set up wizard.
This is going to guide you through
a collection of screens to set up
Android Studio and pretty much always
we're going to just select the defaults.
All right.
So, I'm going to hit next,
I want all these boxes checked.
Note that this requires 3.8 gigabytes
of space and we only download about
a gigabyte, so after this, there's
going to be even more downloading.
I'm going to hit Next.
So license agreement here.
You can go to read it if you'd like.
I'm going to go ahead and hit, I Agree.
Yes!
I agree more.
Okay, I'm all right with all of
these standard install locations.
Right, going to say next on the emulator
set up, we'll talk about this later.
Sure, let's make a Start Menu folder and
I'm going to hit install which
will bring me to the screen.
Okay, so this is another loading bar
which might take a little bit of time.
All right, it looks like it completed.
I can go ahead and
take a look at the show details and
I'm not seeing anything
here about huge errors.
So that's good.
All right I'm going to go ahead and
click next.
Okay, so
the install looks like it finished.
I'm going to click finish.
This is the little loading screen for
Android Studio when it starts up.
Okay, now this is asking if I have some
settings from a previous version of
Android Studio.
And I'm pretty sure that you don't, so
you probably want to hit the I don't
have a previous version
of Android Studio, or
I don't want to import my settings.
Go ahead and hit okay.
And just go ahead of downloading
a few more components for me.
Now once you see this screen you
know that you've got Android Studio
up and running.
But the real test to see if
you did everything correctly
will be if you can make
your first app using it.
All right so this completes
the installation video and
now you're going to do
this process on your own.
All right, I'm going to download
Android studio on a Mac.
Note that the screencast
was study April 6, 2015.
And the reason I'm saying that is
because sometimes this
process will change.
We will always provide you with text
instructions for the install process.
And we will keep those
instructions up to date.
So if things look a little bit
different here and there don't worry,
check out the text install instructions.
All right, and with that little
mini note, let's get started.
Okay so the first thing you're going to
do is click the link in the instructor
note below to get to
the Android Studio homepage.
Don't try typing this out, just click
the link in the instructor notes.
Once you're here there's going to be
a pretty obvious button that says
Download Android Studio,
and it should say for Mac.
Go ahead and click it.
At this point you'll see
a license agreement.
You can read it if you like and then
go ahead scroll down, click that you've
read it and then click this download
Android Studio from that button.
Okay, so
it started downloading here for me and
you should be able to see that this
download is a couple hundred megabytes.
Once it's downloaded go ahead and
double-click it.
You should see this big beautiful
screen that says Android Studio.
And, as with most applications,
you're going to go ahead and
click Android Studio and
drag it into your Applications folder,
that'll copy over.
After you've successfully done that,
you can go ahead to double click
Android Studio which will try
to actually open Android Studio.
You might get a warning about it being
downloaded from the web but we did mean
to download this and we did mean to
run it so go ahead and click open.
All right,
in this little screen should appear to
load up the installation process.
Alright and
here we are at the walk a wizard.
What follows is going to be a list
of screens and licenses and
you pretty much just want
to keep the defaults.
And click Next.
This is a screen asking me where
my Java development kit is.
Now we just installed that and
it's actually making
a guess about where it is.
If it isn't guessing,
you can click the Detect button, and
if that isn't working, you can try
navigating your file system to go
exactly to where you downloaded it.
If you're having trouble with this step
It probably means that there were issues
with downloading the Java development
kit, you might have downloaded the wrong
file, or just something may
not be configured right.
Try going through
the instructions again,
or checking out
the troubleshooting documents.
Everything seems to be working here, so
I'm going to go ahead and click next.
Now we're not doing anything too crazy,
so
I'm going to choose
a standard installation.
Here are some of the licenses
that I was talking about.
Go ahead and click on the first
license and say accept.
That accept all the these
licenses down here.
You'll have to click on
the next license set here and
also hit accept and this will let you
finish the Android Studio set up wizard.
Okay, when I click finish it's actually
going to download a lot of stuff and
what all of this entails is downloading
a couple gigs of data, which is sort of
a huge amount of stuff to download, so
be patient this might take some time.
If you see this window, go ahead and
type in your password and
the candy cane stripes here mean
that this is close to done.
Awesome, and once you're done,
you should see this screen.
Hopefully there's a lot of positive
language like successfully,
installation pass, successfully created.
If you see any errors here,
it could mean that there
are errors with the installation.
But things look good, so
I'm going to go ahead and click Finish.
Now, once you see this screen,
you know that you've got
Android Studio up and running.
So, great job.
But the real test is going to be seeing
if we did everything correctly enough
that we can create our
own apps using it.
All right, so
now you've watched me do the steps once.
I want you to go ahead and
download Android Studio yourself.